yeah welcome to this video on round
12 of the world rapid
championships i covered
both the carltons and um kayaking's game
for
round 11 and um this video will be about
those two players games of around 12.
i'll start with um with carlsen
and he had white against ivan chuck who
just
the round before lost this game
against kayaking first having a winning
position
then maybe a draw and then he
overstepped the time
for no reason at all in an endgame
yeah so he's now playing carson so
you would expect that evan chuck is
going down in flames but um
experience suggests that you never know
what is going to happen with evan shook
he can play a brilliant game next day
play like a pazza and then like
like the biggest genius of all time
again so
okay so
we have a nimso coming knight f3
and um quite weird move 94 but
um it seems to be playable i think it
has been played even by karpov in the
world championship match
queen c2 covering uh the c3
knight and then f5 so black tries to set
up a sort of dutch formation here
white going g3 yeah the bishop is just
uh
best on on g2 in these kind of positions
using the long diagonal and black also
if he enchanted his bishop yeah here
white
played um a very direct move
he could have also just castled for
instance
but he played knight d2 which um really
forces
the upcoming sequence here black
needed to take and play knight e6
he needed to do this because of this
this pin on the long diagonal of the
knight
so um this was sort of forced and now
white went d5
so white of course doesn't want to
exchange he wants to
get some space advantage in the center
continue with e4 at a later stage
and trying to prove that his space
advantage
sort of um yeah is worth more
than those weaknesses
we see what happens it's a very
complicated game will
will arise here knight to a6
trying to use the c5 square
so all very normal this bishop also
makes sense on this diagonal
covering the square and putting some
pressure on the knight
black one queen f6 yeah and now
a very um committal move by carlsen
i'm not sure to be honest this game is a
bit
too complicated for me
it's very hard to to understand what is
going on
and the this kind of position is
strategically super complicated
i'm not quite sure
what what are the alternatives here
white certainly could have played
a less committal move he played e4 just
to show what happened
and this allowed f4
and i don't i'm not sure i think just
speaking for myself i most likely
wouldn't have played
this as white but
i i sort of didn't like don't like
this pawn coming up to f4 and giving
back
black space on the king side of course
for compensation white will get play on
the queen side we'll see this
um he could have played some some other
stuff here yeah
rook b1 or no no
queen a4 yeah maybe not this was hanging
so i'm just saying e4 is really um the
kind of the the hardest move to
and not the hardest but the most direct
move to play but it gives
like some some play as well with their
form
rookie eight queen d3 i think
trying to to play c5 and have to
to sort of pressurize the knight on a6
like close the position up
and white played knight b3 and tending
c4 to c5
so black retreated here and
white now took on d6
also quite a committal move
and c5 this was his idea
to open up the queen side i mean
black obviously has somewhat strange
looking pieces there
but um it doesn't seem like white can
take
um yeah immediate advantage out of this
so black just moved the queen away and
white gained further space here
very difficult very difficult position
black went d6
and now white played c6 bishop c8
and this is really a weird position
those pieces here i mean especially the
knight on b8
the bishop on c8 of course has some
something to do on the
on the king side potentially but this
knight on b8 looks just horrible but on
the other hand black has ideas like f3
here
and this is also a problem so let's show
what white played he played c5
a super direct move
well what else could white have done the
problem is black is uh
intending this move here f3 and then you
would need to
go to uh h1 which is really a terrible
position for the bishop
it's kind of uh dead on on h1
so white needs to do something about
this and it's not quite clear what he
should do
if he would um let's say yeah he cannot
move the rook
for instance let's say he would move the
rook then black
has got the opportunity to even enter on
f2 which is
isn't so great either and
this is why he he played this very
aggressive c5 move
one idea of this move is if black plays
let's see what he played black played f3
one idea is
to do the following if black plays
bishop a6
immediately in this position white can
can move the queen and if black then
would take on f1 i just want to show
this kind of position
this kind of stuff this is actually very
interesting
to look at because look at this knight
this knight doesn't have any square it
cannot go to d7
and a6 is also controlled by white's
queen
if black plays a move like f3 next
yeah let's say yeah okay white might
might play this here so to prevent this
but um yeah black doesn't have any
direct play here white can also
try to activate his bishop
and it's not easy to see how this knight
should come into play
maybe you would even sacrifice it on c6
i'm sorry ah and
even sacrificed it on c6
so quite um quite an interesting
position what black did
is he played f3 first
oh i'm sorry i need to
ah i'm back i'm sorry i need to get me
some water i have a slight coat here
he played f3 and then um
white really needed to go to h1
but now white is intending knight d2 and
take on f3
getting this pawn back so he grabbed
this exchange after all
and now we have a position which is kind
of similar to the one i showed before
with this somewhat stupid looking knight
but here the knight might come here this
is the only
kind of route imaginable to activate
this piece
white plate knight d2 he wants this pawn
back and activate his bishop
knight knight to a6
queen here and queen b3 and still
this knight doesn't have much squares
yeah queen g5
white was intending a3 so black does
playing a counter attack on the knight
he captured and this position is
actually
quite unclear black
took took the knight counter sacrifice
but let's have a look at alternatives he
could have played queen h5
also then a3
traps this knight so um
yeah black needs to get his material
back
yeah this kind of position and this is
maybe
unclear about about even maybe white has
some strong counter play here a7
to c7 and possibly winning all these
pawns
and
yeah very difficult position but white
is
um quite okay here
this is also why ivan shook
just sacked the exchange here
to enter with the queen and have the
ideas to
play night here or night here yeah and
in this position
um carlson actually made them a
rather big mistake but it's
very difficult and still um need to take
into account that this is a rapid game
he played a3 what he could have done is
um rook b1
and the point of this move
is that um yeah a3 is just threatened
now
black cannot capture of course because
he's in a pin here
so what is black supposed to do he can
play rook b6
and um in this position the problem is
if white goes a3
that's 93 which is actually similar to
the game
but white can play this
this move and this is quite
quite strange that this is possible if
he takes with the knight now
rook takes b6 ab6 queen a6
is even winning for white this is a
winning attack
funny enough hard to believe but it is
really winning
you get you get get a huge attack here
so black cannot take with the knight he
needed to take with the queen
and then white can actually exchange
here
rook a1 knight c3 and now the insane
move
rook takes a7 of course
still this is just a computer line which
is impossible for a human to play
not even for magnus so take cm
or maybe to g2 not sure g2
knight here and actually you've got
enough counter play with the c
pawn to secure a draw yeah it's just an
insane line which no human would ever
consider but you can check this with the
computer if you like it's really working
so he didn't play this rook b1 move but
a3
which is perfectly understandable but
now knight d3
and this is a very strong piece of
course now and f2
is really vulnerable he played bishop g4
activating the bishop
but now black really has play against f2
yeah black gives himself some extra
space for the king
so that he can escape here
if white gives a check or tries to enter
with the queen
queen b5 c4
the idea is if white takes you've got
rook b8 to b2
and it's completely over
no no defense at all this is almost made
now
so he cannot take played queen b7
and now black just retreated to cover
those pawns queen e3 also would
would be winning but this is uh is
enough
king g2 king g7 just playing it safe
don't need to rush he has black
first of all he secures his king
and now black starts the final counter
attack
while counter attacks the wrong word
white doesn't have an attack
he tries with queen c7 but now queen e2
is just a killer move
what is white supported supposed to do
if you would move the rook
somewhere then you've got this coming
check check
and it's it's a checkmate coming up
so um very very nice line
oops so
2 was the game and now magnus played
queen e7
queen have to check king h3 and now the
final blow here
knight f4 and this is actually now a
mate
white could take he resigned but this
could have happened
and now you see rook and queen
setting up for the final attack here oh
this is even
what i wanted to play this move
and this this leads to a checkmate
all right so quite a surprise here
carson losing with white against ivan
shook
after he played this terrible
yeah and it's not a terrible game that
he played against kayaking the round
before
ivan should did but he just uh yeah
blundered his time so to say
and right after this he um he beat
carson so
he played a huge role in the tournament
standing first gifting a whole point to
kayaking
and then beating beating carlsen here
okay so let's see what kayaking did
in the meantime in this round he played
rajabov
with black so
were job of certainly trying to gain
some ground in the tournament he didn't
didn't really do much good
the first couple of rounds and we have
scotch here scotch opening
and actually the scotch gambit very rare
guest
and top level tournament practice and
for good reason it really
isn't such a great opening quite
surprised that um
that rajab played this bishop c5
c3 and um yeah black
played the save move here knight to f6
after which he captured on d4 so we
transpose into the the main line of the
the italian game and which is by all
accounts pretty harmless for black
so he went rook c1 uh i'm not so sure
about
the theoretical state here i mean i play
this as black even but
it it's rather harmless opening and i
didn't really
i never really looked at it in much
detail the thing
if you look at this game here um white
very very quickly gets to a position
where he is at best equal
it's very strange choice by white
just a couple of moves here
and you ask yourself what is white's
compensation for this pawn
okay black has this double pawns but
still it's a weakness on d4
he played bishop c4
and kayaking just queen f6 to pile up on
on the d pawn white played bishop d5
rook d8 and now exchange he basically
tries to
exchange all this down to to a draw
yeah and this is basically right out of
the opening
very strange opening play by
rajabov the only question is can black
win this
and
for a while there's not too much
happening
pretty normal moves all around
yeah white tries to stay active black
doesn't have a past pawn yet so
it's um quite still quite some hope for
white now he couldn't
avoid the queen trade though and we
enter a double rook
end game but white is still quite active
so he should have some chances to
to hold but um it's difficult
certainly not a very nice
position to defend i'm not quite sure
what what is this with rajabov's clock
time here
i think the relayer had some some
trouble here
he certainly wasn't on minus seconds
so black um
managed to exchange the b for the a pawn
so he has a passport now
but it still doesn't look too
frightening
so white set up a blockade here black is
of course still clearly better
but um i just want to show
one particular this move
i was really absolutely surprised that
he played f4 which looks really
yeah weird i mean maybe i would need to
look at this
a bit longer to tell if this is
maybe winning anyway for black
but f4 really um i don't understand
because you just
weaken your own king side so much
that um it i think it's it's
considerably helps
like to to win this game we see what's
what's going on here
this is actually a very nice move white
played
look back now if he would have taken
here
then black immediately
would use this these weaknesses here
caused by a form so white couldn't take
the pawn
and he needed to retreat and now black
gets to exchange one rook
and he actually gets the rook behind
his past pawn so this is a winning end
game now
and kayaking is doing a good job in
converting this
of course it's also obvious here that
this is just
terribly weakening so f4 is really a
move that's hard to understand
and now this is pretty simple technique
white
can maybe gain the a pawn but
black has just everything nicely
controlled and we'll just
grab all those weak pawns
yeah and this is pretty easy with two
extra pawns and for
and his king here cut off
so i don't think i need to show much
here
so black one and um all in all
quite strange game if you ask me very
unambitious opening
leading directly to uh to a worse end
game
and then he played this somewhat weird
move f4 i mean maybe it was uh
close to lost anyway but this really
helped like
so a pretty in comparison easy win for
kayaking
while um ivan should beat carlton so
now magnus was only leading by half a
point
so it uh might get it get interesting
and um
in the next round so let's see um
should i start a new video i think i
should i don't want to make these
one-hour things
all and on and on again so i'll i cut it
here and start um with a separate video
of round 13 so
let's uh let's see more in round 13.